Our family milk cow, Cora,
is officially dry, and we really hope she's pregnant.
Back in August, we took her over to a friend's house
who had a ball when we drove through the driveway.
She was so happy to see other cows
because she is a lone cow on our homestead.
We saw the ball get the job done within the first few minutes,
but I left her there for a few days just to make sure the job was done.
So I took a blood sample from her towel,
and then I put it on this test strip I got from Amazon,
and it's kinda similar to a home pregnancy test,
but you use blood instead of urine.
The results take 20 minutes to appear,
so we hung out and played with some Turkey feathers.
Now, I did show positive before the 20 minutes,
but I just wanted to make sure.
But this is at 20 minutes.
It definitely is a positive result.
So she is 12 weeks pregnant right now.
She had her last cow in July of 2023.
So it's been over a year since she had her last calf.
And she won't have her next calf until July 2025.
So that would have given her a two year break between calving.
That's something that's not super common in the dairy industry,
but in the homestead, you can definitely do that.
I've only just dried her up this week,
so we had a long time of having Her a milk before
we needed to dry her up. I just needed the break.
She needed the break. She start her supply started to really drop.
But now she's gonna have a nice long break before she has her new calf.
And we all can't wait.